good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have a special ability to create
something amazing that can change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to
communicate effectively
[Music]
this is gonna blow away people
especially your fanbase listening you
know I speak a lot and I talk over
people and I'm loud and intense but all
of my success has been predicated on
listening whether I'm doing it with my
ears for with my eyes still I use it
probably communication pretending you're
building on what Garrett said I think
communication is - a two-way street but
being able to articulate and communicate
what it is that I'm trying to
communicate is something that I find I
focus on all day long every time I speak
it turns out in corporate America today
and I teach this now you know I've
taught at Notre Dame and MIT the
graduating cohorts I explain this to
them when you're leading when you want
to be a leader you have to articulate
your idea in 90 seconds or less you have
to explain why you're the right person
to lead and above all you have to know
your numbers you can see it happen on
Shark Tank it works in the real world
too - and frankly Shark Tank is the real
world because it's real capital so I use
that and I teach it and I think
everybody should think about that
explaining your vision clearly
succinctly in a short period of time is
up being really important
before a conversation put your mind in
the other person's body and think what's
good for them right because you don't
want to just be the selfish Bulldog
that's running through life and not
thinking about other people and also a
conversations gonna go better if you
think about what is gonna help this
person achieve their goals what
motivates them what are their values so
the best story I've ever heard for this
is Charlie Charlie wanted to move to New
York City but his job was in Washington
DC he could have just quit could've just
put in his two weeks notice he could've
done it via email because he was really
scared to have this conversation but
instead he got some time with his boss
sat down and said hey I really like it
here I really like the people but I'm
unhappy in DC all my friends are in New
York my best friends in New York it's
important to me to be happy I need to
move but I want to do this in the best
way possible for you so does that mean
working remotely does that mean you guys
hire my replacement I train them and it
takes a couple months for me to go get
my ideal outcome which is to go to New
York like how can I do this
so it's good for both of us and they had
a great conversation they ended up with
Charlie working remotely first person of
his position to do it and he had a 50%
raise because he switched from employee
to contractor so that incredible outcome
couldn't have happened if he hadn't
thought about the other person so I was
um taking off my man thong and hmm and I
was like oh my god and you were like oh
my god he has a wife like yo dog I'm so
pissed right now you'll never believe
what happened I was over there
ordering the delicious ass McRib
sandwich you know what I'm saying and
they forgot the mother freaking pickle
you know what I'm saying yes I do know
what you're saying that the McRib
sandwich is a culinary mystery meat that
needs pickle to enhance its
deliciousness I also know that using
filler words makes you sound on
confident unsure of yourself
unprofessional and dare I say a dumb as
a stump so what about you do you use
filler words and if so what is it if
you're not sure ask your friends or
family because if you don't know I'm
sure they will because that's exactly
how I found out that I use the word um
all the time Tracy one day about six
years ago came up he was like you say um
all the time I was like I do I told her
to start pointing it out every time she
noticed there heard me used the word um
she would say um and that was my cue to
start paying attention but something
remarkable happened after a little while
of being ultra aware of myself I would
actually start correcting myself when
I'd say I might be like uh um and it was
really awkward and uncomfortable when I
was having a conversation with somebody
else and eventually I stopped it took
hard work being hyper aware of what
you're saying and a little bit paranoid
but eventually I kicked it and so can
you and a great tip I would give to you
is when you're talking and you feel like
comment on just pause and pick up where
you left off and eventually you will be
able to kick the filler were to have it
a bit of a warning what I'm about to
tell you to do is terrifying and most of
us spend our entire lives trying to
avoid it but like a pap smear it's over
fast and it really works I just did it
did you catch it if not and you missed
it here it goes again that was a live
demonstration of the three-second I a
pee the intentional awkward pause now
why on God's green earth would you ever
want to do that I'll tell you because
being a really really good listener is
one of the most underrated secrets to
success it's crucial if you want to be
more charismatic more persuasive and a
better negotiator Plus really listening
to someone and having them feel truly
heard is one of the biggest gifts you
could ever give the problem is most of
us suck at listening and we don't even
know it we're always interrupting others
with our brilliant idea
our feedback and most often it's the
whoa my god that is so true and always
interrupting people as I was saying it's
often the way that we suck the most now
I'm probably one of the worst offenders
out there but I am consistently working
on this and I have to say the ia P is a
lifesaver not so long ago I used it with
my stepson Zane and had an unbelievable
result so Zane was home on Christmas
break from college and he invited me to
go for cappuccino slow a little back
story here in the 10 years plus that
we've been in each other's lives he had
never really asked me for a life advice
so we get to this place Cafe Minerva and
were hanging out and Zane starts to tell
me all about his life and what he might
want to do with it he's very very
involved with music he's involved in
acting in all these creative things so
basically he's asking me for the kind of
advice that I give for a living
so you could imagine every single part
of me just wanted to jump in and tell
him what to do and tell him what I think
and yadda yadda yadda but I practiced
the I ap and I just sat there and I
zipped it now every time I did this and
I just shut up it was amazing because he
would just reveal more and more insights
he'd find new things to talk about he'd
find his own insights that were way
better than anything I could have told
him it was really really amazing now I
have to be honest my body was literally
uncomfortable being silent so every time
he would come to an end of a sentence I
would sit and see if there is more and
it was absolutely awesome by the end of
three hours we had the most beautiful
conversation and we left that cafe
feeling more connected and more intimate
than I think we've ever felt so just a
little story to show that it really
really works another way to become a
great conversationalist is to question
for clarification never assume that you
understand what the other person is
saying or trying to say instead if you
have any doubt at all ask how do you
mean or how do you mean exactly and then
just pause and wait
this is the most powerful question I've
ever learned for guiding and controlling
a conversation it's almost impossible
not to answer this question when you ask
how do you mean the other person cannot
stop himself or herself from answering
more extensively you can then follow up
with other open-ended questions and keep
the conversation rolling along begin
with the end in mind how do you want
them to feel at the end of the
conversation
how do you want to feel at the end of
the conversation what would you love
them to think believe or do at the end
and what do you want to think believe or
do at the end look always begin with
that people forget this all the time
they just have a spark of emotion or
something they have to deliver and they
just deliver it without knowing where to
go and if you don't know where to go you
end up in 50 different sort of open
alleys of conversation you open all
these loops of conversation that don't
get closed people get confused or you
end up starting a fight that you didn't
even know you were having because you
just weren't clear on where you wanted
to go it doesn't mean that you'll always
get there exactly because again humility
says you're to learn together but at
least you have a sense of what feeling
you want do you want her to trust you at
the end of the conversation do you want
him to know how you felt and that's all
you're after like what is that you
really want at the end of the
conversation
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what was the rule that most
applies to you that you're going to
immediately implement somehow into your
life or your business please let me know
I'd love to hear from you leave it down
in the comments below I also want to
give a quick shout out to Anthony Avena
Anthony thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
doing the video review of it I really
appreciate the support man and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the book today I'm
going to be reviewing a book for you
guys called your one-word by Evan
Carmichael so thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon
how do you communicate authentically how
do you figure out what to say and what
not to say in a way that's authentic and
what Fred says and I really believe this
is true is it starts from the
fundamental understanding that there is
no truth there's my truth there's your
truth and everything is subjective and
so if you always start from the position
of this is what I believe I don't expect
you to believe it I don't think you have
to believe it I'm not saying it's true
you can actually always communicate
authentically because if you walk in the
room and this gets worse as you get more
senior here's the answer you're not
giving anyone else any room to say
anything and if you walk in the room and
say I believe this
for this reason what do you believe if
you share your truth in that language
you give people room to authenticate to
communicate authentically and that is
hugely important to these relationships
at any stage paraphrase the speaker's
words in your own words so after you
have nodded and smiled you can then say
well let me see if I've got this writer
let me see if I understand you exactly
what you're saying is this and then you
repeat it back in your own words by
paraphrasing the speaker's words you
demonstrate in no uncertain terms that
you are genuinely paying attention and
making every effort to understand his or
her thoughts or feelings and the
wonderful thing is when you practice
effective listening other people will
begin to find you fascinating they will
want to be around you they will feel
relaxed and happy in your presence
because when you listen to other people
you make them feel important Nelson
Mandela is a particularly special case
study in the leadership world because he
is universally regarded as a great
leader you can take other personalities
and depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader he was actually the son of
a tribal chief and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak you
will be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week
even people who consider themselves good
leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what I think
but I'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late the
skill to hold your opinions to yourself
until everyone has spoken does two
things one it gives everybody else the
feeling that they have been heard it
give me gives everyone else the ability
to feel that they have contributed and
two you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody
don't nod no simply sit there take it
all in and the only thing you're allowed
to do is ask questions so that you can
understand what they mean and why they
have the opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn it sounds easy
it's not practice being the last to
speak that's what Nelson Mandela did